翻訳: Mizuho WATANABE
校正: Hiroko Kawano
（ムックリの演奏開始）
（ムックリの演奏終了）
（拍手）
（トンコリの演奏開始）
（トンコリの演奏終了）
せっかく みなさんと 出会えたので
北海道のアイヌの唄を
みなさんと一緒に歌いたいんですが
いかがでしょうか？
（拍手）
（トンコリの音）
僕が たぶん 何言ってるかさっぱり
ちんぷんかんぷんで 分からないと思いますが
僕に 食らいついてきてくれますか？
（拍手）
それじゃあ みなさん立ち上がって
手拍子しながら 一緒に歌ってみましょう！
（演奏開始）
（手拍子開始）
（アイヌ語の唄開始）
（アイヌ語の唄/演奏終了）（手拍子終了）
（拍手）
イヤイライケレ～
（アイヌ語でどうもありがとう）
（拍手）
最初に ―
一番最初に弾いた楽器が
「ムックリ」 という
北海道に伝わる口琴です
で 次に弾かせてもらったのが
樺太アイヌの人たちが
北海道のアイヌの人たちに遺してくれた
「トンコリ」 といいます
こうやって 楽器を弾きながら
日本中を 旅するときもあります
そして 僕は
北海道の先住民であるアイヌの血を引いて
この北海道に生まれました
ですが 僕が小さい頃というのは
まだ 僕らたちアイヌ民族は
先住民族ではありませんでした
学校に行くということは
ただ１人のマイノリティーになるということで
非常に 恐ろしかったです
６年間 口きいたことがありません
怖かった
生き地獄だったんです
でも そうこうしながら 中学・高校を出て
僕は アイヌのいないところに
行きたかったんです
自分の血を 呪っていた
なんで 俺はアイヌなんだ？
なんで みんなと違うんだろう？
そして ―
北海道を離れます
沖縄に逃げたんです
ある種の逃亡ですね
自分の血からの逃亡です
そして 沖縄に行って
初めて 僕はアイヌですって
心を開いて喋れるようになったんです
そして 彼らはそれを受け入れてくれた
やっぱり どこか近いものがあるので
それで 初めて自分を隠さずに暮らすことが
18歳の僕に できたんです
そして もう自由になって
うれしくて うれしくて
はぁー って ―
隠さなくていいんだって ―
あるがままに 生きていいんだ
っていうのを 教わりました
そして ―
もう 浮かれ気分で
遊んでばっかりいますよね
（笑）
ほんとにもう
君は どうしたらいいんだ？
ぐらいの状態だったんですけど
そうしてるときに
まぁ 沖縄って 音楽の島なので
いろんなミュージシャンに 出会うんですね
そして ―
あるバンドの リハーサルに行ったんです
そして リハーサルが終わって
あるミュージシャンが
「おぉ 基（もとい）くん
アイヌの唄 歌ってくれないか？
アイヌの唄 教えてくれよ」
「はぁ？ 知らんよ 歌えんよ」
「バカか お前は！
唄も歌えねえで なにが民族だ！」
ハッとしたんですね
沖縄に甘えてるだけであった 僕が
その言葉を［聞いて］ もう
北海道に帰らんといけない
帰って 学ばなきゃいけない
そして 帰るんです
そして帰っても 北海道という土地で
何をしていいのか 分からないんです
まず おじいちゃん おばあちゃんの
ところに通いました
アイヌの おじいちゃん おばあちゃん
僕は 小さい頃から 家の中に
アイヌ文化がありました
そして おじいちゃん おばあちゃんの
膝の上で
アイヌ文様を習いました
アイヌの唄が 子守歌だったこともあります
その おじいちゃん おばあちゃんのところに
聞き取りに行っているときに
その 小さいときの記憶が
僕の中に ぼーん！ぼーん！ぼーん！
と蘇るんです
いろんなアイヌの唄を聞いて
「あ そこ違う」 とか 分かるんです
そんな自分が こう どんどん出てくる
隠して 自分で塞いでいたものの蓋が
年寄りの愛情で また開いたと ―
僕の中から アイヌの文化が
湧き出るようになってきた
湧き出るのは いいんですけど
どう生活していいのか 分からないんです
日本と呼ばれる社会の中で
アイヌとして どう生きていっていいのかが
分からなかった 20代の僕がいます
また生活は すさんでいきます
ほぼ アル中でした
ライブで 稼いだ金は
その晩のうちに なくなります
世の中が悪いんだ ―
あいつらが悪いんだ ―
俺は どうせマイノリティーだ
恨んで恨んで恨んでいたんです
でもその状態って 僕を幸せにはしない
ましてや 誰も幸せにはしない
僕のトンコリ聴いて
誰が 幸せになるんだろうと
今 考えるとです
でも 悩んで悩んで
どう生活していっていいのか
夜中に アイヌ文様を
自然と切り出すように なったんですね
静かじゃないと 切れなかったんです
精神的に弱い僕は
真夜中に切って 昼間 寝る ―
昼間 寝るってことは
大勢の中に 行かなくていいからです
逃げていたんです
ただ これじゃいけないなと思って
僕は アイヌ文様で
プロダクトを作りだしました
ものづくりを 始めました
まず ペンダントを作りました
Ｔシャツを作りました
それは なぜかっていうと
みなさんの生活の中で
アイヌ文様を 楽しんでもらうことで
アイヌ文様の コマーシャルにもなる
アイヌ文様を 広めることができる
そして いろんな人とつながっていける
やっと 僕に道が拓けたんです
その道が拓けるまで
40年の時間が かかっています ―
生まれてから
40年間 僕は闇の中にいたんです
でも 拓けてからは
僕の 高度成長期が 始まるんです
（笑）
まず 日本という社会の中に
トライしなきゃいけない ―
アイヌ文様で
前例がないことなんです
道がないって 分かったときに
僕は すっきりしました
いつでも 地獄に堕ちていいんだと
「よし！」 って
タフになるしか なかったんです
差別されてる暇なんかない
傷つく前にタフになれ！
僕の中に 言葉が出てきました
「よし！」 と
いろんな企業と つながって
ものを 作っていかなきゃいけないことを
学びました
最初
「いらっしゃいませ」 も言えない
「ありがとうございます」 も言えないで
小樽運河で ペンダントを並べてました
なぜ この人たちに
頭下げなきゃいけないんだ？
「なんでだよ」 と
このペンダント カッコいいと言われても
何言ってんだよと［考える］
自分が どこかにいた
でも 勇気を振り絞ったんです 僕は
で 何をしたかっていうと
「ありがとうございます」
感謝を 伝えたんです
そしたら 僕の中で
何かが 解放されたんですね
僕が 許されたんです
その瞬間 僕は
北海道で 札幌で ―
日本の中で
自分の居場所を 見つけたんです
やっと
「ありがとうございます」
この 単純な一言が
アイヌとして 僕に生きる道を
拓いてくれたんです
そこには 多くの出会いがありました
その出会いが 僕を導いてくれました
多くの人たちが
「シサム」 日本の人たちです
そして その人たちは
僕らのアイヌ文様を 理解してくれました
「安売りをするな」
僕は その時から ―
札幌っていう 先住民が暮らす
世界的にみても大きな都市って
そんなにいっぱい ないんです ―
すべてが 可能性になったんです
僕にとって マイナスだったことが
すべて 可能性になったんです
そして トライすべき道が
いっぱい できたんです
「トライできるんだ！」
これだけで 僕はうれしい
日本の社会の中で居場所を見つけ
トライすることがある
自分で存在を アピールできる
そして ご先祖様から借りている文化を
未来に返すんです
僕は今 ご先祖様たちから
この唄 文様 ―
いろんなものを お借りしてます
それを 未来の子たち ―
アイヌの子たちにも 日本の子たちにも
返さなきゃいけないんです
そうすることで
北海道の文化になるんです ―
アイヌ文化が
そのときに 始まることは
僕の中では 「依存のない共存」 なんです
経済的にも 精神的にも 依存のない
互いに しっかり支え合う
ものを作ったり 生活していくことが
始まると思ったんです
面白いなって
僕は初めて日本の人たちと協力して
トライするべきことを 見つけたんです
うれしくてうれしくて しょうがなかった
僕は 日本の中に
居場所がないと思っていたから
見つけたら もう
こんな うれしくてうれしくて
ホント ご先祖様にも感謝したし
そして 日本の文化にも感謝しました
僕は 日本中 旅して歩きました
日本の文化を
学ばなきゃいけないと思ったからです
お寺に行って 手を合わすって
こんなに 素晴らしいことなんだ
日本の文化を 学んで学んで
アイヌ文様で
雪の結晶を切ることができました
和の家紋を学ぶことで
アイヌ文様が また生まれたんです
そんな不思議が
僕の中には いっぱいあって
でもそれは みなさんと
出会えたからだと思っています
そして ご先祖様が
僕に いろんなトライを
遺してくれたからだと思っています
今 ご先祖様が遺してくれた文化と
みなさまに 出会えたことで
僕は 幸せになっています
ほんとに 今日は 出会ってくれて
ありがとうございます
イヤイライケレ～
（拍手）